- Wowzers.
Like I'm, like lighting
is really gonna make this
any better right now.
This, oh, look, welcome to heaven.
It sucks here (laughs).
Uh oh, have I officially
broken from reality
and entered an alternative dimension?
Hi guys, welcome to "Saturdiary".
It is 1:30pm on Saturday and I am still
laying in bed because I can today.
We have been shooting
Dirty Thirty all week,
and it's been so wonderful, and,
but it's been a lot of
long days and so today,
Saturday, I have off,
and I'm gonna sit in bed
until I can't anymore.
That said, let's look back at shooting
Dirty Thirty this week.
(party horn)
(mumbles)
- [Voiceover] We're all getting Gilled,
look at pose of Gil.
Where's the one that you have Taylor?
- Mine (unintelligible)
- [Voiceover] Oh my god,
you got the baby headshot.
This happened on Friday
right before we left
we found this photo in our green room,
what, somehow we're getting Gilled.
(ragtime piano music)
(zany music)
- [Voiceover] (mumbles}
did you see our stand-in?
- [Voiceover] I did, they look duh good.
- [Voiceover] Ooh.
- Mamajubu. Mamajubu.
Mamajubu. Mamajubu. Mamajubu.
Mamajubu. Mamajubu. Mamajubu. Mamajubu.
(party horn)
(circus music)
- [Voiceover] Carrot dip
with what were these?
- Cranberry pumpkin seed crackers.
- [Voiceover] What the?
- Two completely obsessed
technological humans
working on work in between other work.
- I was trying to get it in in 10 seconds,
Snap Chat has ruined me.
- [Voiceover] No social media on set.
- No social media on the set.
No photographing on the set.
But
- [Voiceover] Go on.
(flute music "The Sound of Silence")
- [Voiceover] Yes, oh
my god, yeah, oh my god.
- I got it, I got it.
- You got it?
(party horn)
- Good morning Fridiary, it is Wednesday.
I'm trying to rush to the dentist's office
before going to set for
Dirty Thirty because
again, I lost the crown
in the back of my mouth.
To be fair, it's a temporary crown and I
should have gotten my
permanent crown already,
but, I didn't make an
appointment before starting
Dirty Thirty and it's
really difficult to get
into the dentist when
you're shooting a film.
But basically it's like
I have a raw nerve in the
back of my mouth that is
super sensitive to like
air, and food, and water and
it's like a lot of things.
We have press on set today.
We have Entertainment
Tonight, MTV, and another one
that's very similar to the other two.
Gonna be talking to us
on set, I don't wanna
look like the weird girl
that's just touching her tongue
to the gaping empty tooth
space in the back of her mouth
during our all the interviews,
so let's go get that fixed.
Look at all of the business happening.
There is so much getting done.
And Lauren is here doing this eye makeup,
did I tell you guys that
Lauren and Taylor are here
from Camp Takota?
Yeah!
Oh, and here's a lovely
picture of all of us with
the mom from Boy Meets World.
I know.
Oh, wait, guys did I tell you?
I changed my phone background to this.
- I got corn on it,
- [Voiceover] Oh the corn.
- I get the chopped tomatoes on it.
- Sure.
- And then I also get the hot sauce.
- [Voiceover] On it.
- On it?
- Yeah.
- Do you do cheese?
- Yes, I do cheese.
- Do you do veggies?
- Yes, I do veggies.
- So what kind of
- Excuse me, no press.
(ragtime piano)
(flute "The Sound of Silence")
- Look who's on set, again!
- Hi.
- Hi, you're so tired from school?
- So tired, school is rough.
- Mike had to do school on
set because he's only 17.
What did you do for school today?
- I emailed my gym teacher.
- You emailed your
- That's it.
- Gym teacher?
- Your trainer?
- No, literally my gym teacher back home.
- [Voiceover] Oh, Adam, you look amazing.
- I'm running for mayor.
- [Voiceover] (laughs)
(zany music)
(party horn)
- [Voiceover] So Lauren is modeling the
biggest trend in facial tattoos.
- (laughs)
- [Voiceover] It's my face,
which, this might be a spoiler,
but someone in the movie
will be wearing a tattoo
of my face.
It looks great.
I mean, I believe at one
point it looked great.
- Oh yeah.
(cheering and laughing)
- You're goin' down, three, two one.
(party horn)
- Okay, so every Friday the
crew wears Hawaiian shirts,
and so me and Mamrie decided
to wear Hawaiian shirts today.
Just so we can be part of it.
- Yeah, she did a great job.
- (laughs)
Finally, finally, finally,
look, we're part of it.
We're part of it, we're part of it.
This is, it's what's
slowing down the filming
for this whole bit right now.
We're in, look.
What about Patrick I'm part of it.
We're part of it.
I'm wearing my Hawaiian shirt too.
Yeah, I'm into it.
- Explaining, you know the geniuses.
- That's how you know
the bit works, when you
explain it to someone.
TGIF.
Wow, what a time that was.
Also if you want more
behind the scenes action,
mild mild action, shooting Dirty Thirty,
Brian, (dog barks) Brian
Gramo is our wonderful awesome
behind the scenes person,
he's been putting up blogs
right here almost every day.
Also Dirty Thirty movie has
a Snap Chat that gives you
all of the updates from set
which is kind of not helpful,
tell you to follow now that
we're going into the holidays
we're taking the next week
off from shooting, and then
we come back to shooting
for another eight days
after vacation, so follow
that Snap Chat anyway
'cause I'm sure Brian will
be doing who knows what.
And we have released
Dirty Thirty movie merch,
the official Party Time
t-shirt that you see us wearing
in all the behind-the-scenes,
and photos from set,
they are now available at
Represent.com/dirtythirty.
But for a limited time,
we are only offering them
until we are done shooting
the movie, so make sure
you go order yours right now.
They make great gifts.,
excellent gifts, and gifs.
Don't forget that Hannah,
Mamrie and I, after shooting
Dirty Thirty movie will
be coming to Australia
for some comedy shows.
Some of the shows I think
half of them are sold out,
but there's still some tickets
left for certain areas,
so go check that out and my second book
Grace and Style the Art
of Pretending You Have It
is available (mumbles)
is available for pre-sale, so
please go pre-order your book
right now and then go
to Gracestylebook.com
and enter the sweepstakes,
you could win a style chat
with me.
Lookit.
Fashion.
Anything is fashion when you can't
see the look on their eyes.
And that's it, don't forget
to subscribe to this channel
and like this video leave a comment and
all those fun things.
I've asked you to do too much, so you just
take a break, relax, enjoy
the elephants in the windows
of your Saturday.
I don't know.
(flute music "The Sound of Silence")